dans cette boulangerie au nigeria pas
d'électricité sans générateur à essence
problèmes à cause de la guerre en
ukraine le prix du carburant a explosé
ce qui a des effets directs sur le tarif
des aliments de base
les coûts de production ont énormément
augmenté
et comme tout est lié le prix du pain a
lui aussi augmenté de 40%
une flambée qui s'explique aussi par
sept du coût des céréales matières
premières massivement importé de russie
et d'ukraine par les pays africains
par ailleurs le prix des engrais pour en
produire a augmenté de 30% depuis le
début de la guerre en république
démocratique du congo les tarifs sur les
marchés deviennent inaccessibles pour
les habitants chaque jour il ya une
nouvelle flambée des prix de produits
alimentaires par exemple on a acheté un
sac de sucre à 43 dollar aujourd'hui il
est à 60 dollars il faut que les
autorités interviennent sinon on risque
de mourir de faim une situation qui
selon eux est nu et le fmi a tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé les organisations
redoute une crise alimentaire mondiale à
des niveaux jamais vus auparavant